Salut les mentalos !
Aujourd'hui on va faire ni une astuce,
ni un Master Class, ni quoi que ce soit,
on va jouer avec votre cerveau !
Et pour les plus mentholés d'entre vous,
j'ai une petite annonce à la fin de la vidéo.
Ce sont des jeux qui vont nous permettre
de comprendre un peu mieux notre cerveau. Jeu n°1 :
Vous allez faire mentalement l'addition suivante.
Ne trichez pas, elle n'est pas très compliquée,
faites-la normalement.
+40
+1000
+30
+20
+1000
+10
Est égal à...
5000... ?
Pas du tout !
Le résultat c'est 4100.
Mais la plupart d'entre vous ont dû se tromper
et ce sont fait absorber
par ce qu'on appelle "le tunnel de suffisance".
Notre cerveau et notre logique
adorent les sommes arrondies.
Ce qui fait que 85 % à 95 % d'entre vous,
ce sont trompé dans le résultat
la première fois qu'ils font ce test.
Et moi inclu, je m'étais planté aussi.
Deuxième jeu ! Vous devez compter
en quelques secondes le nombre de F
qu'il y a dans la phrase qui va s'afficher,
là, maintenant, tout de suite.
C'est parti.
Maintenant.
Tic
Tac
Non, je ne fais pas de bruit...
Non, je n'essaie pas de vous déconcentrer.
Attention !
C'est bientôt, maintenant, terminé, fini !
Combien il y avait de "F" ?
Le vrai résultat est 6.
Et vous en avez trouvé surement moins,
encore une fois pour la majorité d'entre vous.
Peut-être pas tout le monde à chaque fois,
mais la majorité en a trouvé moins.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que notre cerveau n'a pas integré les  "of".
Les mots "of".
Le cerveau n'intègre pas les mots courts de liaison.
En réalité il les déduit.
Il ne les lit pas réellement,
il déduit l'ensemble de la phrase.
Jeu du cerveau n°3 ! [chante]
Je vais afficher un texte à l'écran
et vous devez le lire le plus rapidement possible,
à voix haute ou dans votre tête,
mais lisez-le,
le plus rapidement et le plus normalement possible.
C'est parti, maintenant.
Il n'y a rien d'autre à rajouter à ce jeu,
j'espère que ça vous a plu.
C'est un de mes trucs préférés à faire avec l'esprit.
Je m'en étais servi d'ailleurs
pour la communication de mon spectacle en 2014,
parce que je trouvais ça passionnant
et vraiment bluffant !
Jeu n°4, ce sera le dernier pour aujourd'hui.
Encore une fois, c'est avec des mots et des lettres
sur une phrase très courte qui va s'afficher à l'écran.
Vous devez absolument la lire rapidement,
à voix haute ou en chuchotant.
Encore une fois, en vous laissant aller,
maintenant, c'est facile.
Et voilà.
Là encore, dans la majorité des essais,
les personnes évitent un des "la".
Parce qu'il y a 2 "la".
Il y a de marqué: "Il va à la la plage".
Et encore une fois là-haut, ça a corrigé.
La vraie conclusion de ces jeux ,
c'est qu'il ne faut pas toujours se fier à notre mental.
On a l'impression que notre mental,
c'est le truc super puissant
et c'est vraiment ce qu'il y a de plus important,
on peut lui faire une confiance aveugle...
C'est complètement faux !
Il ne faut pas toujours se fier à ce qu'on croit avoir vu,
à ce qu'on croit avoir compris,
à ce qu'on croit avoir entendu...
Puisque là, on l'a vu dans ces 4 jeux,
notre cerveau fait des corrections en permanence.
Il n'est pas fiable à 100% notre cerveau,
parce qu'il veut toujours trouver une cohérence partout.
Et ça, ça fera l'objet d'une prochaine vidéo.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
J'espère que vous avez joué le jeu.
Dites-moi dans les commentaires
là où vous vous êtes trompé,
ou là où vous avez résisté,
sans chercher forcément à résister.
N'oubliez pas de laisser
un puissant et non trompeur pouce en l'air.
Vous pouvez aussi partager cette vidéo
pour voir les résultats de vos amis
ou voir ce que ça leur fait à eux
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Et bien sûr abonnez-vous à la chaine avant de partir.
Puisque le Mental Vlog,
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an,
depuis le 1er janvier jusqu'au 31 décembre.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 11H.
Ciao !
[musique]
Merci d'être resté après l'outro.
Alors j'avais une petite annonce à vous faire.
Souvent dans les messages privés ou par mail,
vous me demandez où est-ce que je joue mon spectacle.
Donc je vous le dis, là, juste rapidement,
comme ça on n'y reviendra plus.
Je joue le 23 septembre à la Garenne-Colombes.
C'est à coté de Paris.
C'est la date la plus proche de Paris
que je fais avec cette tournée-là, avec ce spectacle.
L'avantage d'une tournée,
c'est que je fais le spectacle durant 1H30.
C'est le spectacle en version entière,
alors qu'à Paris on est obligé de jouer qu'une heure.
Donc c'est à la Garenne-Colombes.
C'est très facile d'accès.
Le Transilien, le tramway, le bus,
tout ce que vous voulez.
Ce sera le spectacle qui tourne actuellement, pas celui que je suis en train d'écrire pour l'année prochaine.
C'est le spectacle "Fabien Olicard, Vous Mentalise !"
Si vous n'êtes pas à Paris et que vous voulez voir
ce spectacle, ou le nouveau l'année prochaine,
vous pouvez aller sur le site : www.fabienolicard.fr
pour voir toutes les dates de tournée.
Si il n'y a pas encore votre ville, ne vous inquiétez pas.
Chaque semaine, on rajoute des nouvelles villes.
Et ce qu'il y a de bien après le spectacle,
c'est qu'à la fin de la représentation,
je suis toujours disponible pour qu'on puisse se voir.
Rendez-vous le 23 septembre ou sur une autre date !
Ciao !